sie versüßt dir die weiler du siehst du
die laizer zugeschneit dich mit banken
vom alltag frei sie versüßten die weiter
zu
ich mit weiten von halt sagten frau
das ist
ich will
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe auch heute wieder ein leckeres
plätzchen rezepte und zwar gibt es heute
kleine lukas ihren denn ich jetzt
einfach mal das sind schokolade
plätzchen mit einer leckeren nougat
füllung und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
ganz kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 125 gramm haselnüsse die
habe ich jetzt bereits im magnetic ride
blender zerkleinert und habe sie dann in
der pfanne einfach ohne fett gerüstet
und jetzt sind sie eben wieder abgekühlt
dann habe ich hier 225 gramm butter 100
g puderzucker
ich brauche etwas vanille extrakt eine
prise zimt eine prise salz einen
teelöffel backpulver ich habe ich drei
gelbe 40 gramm kakaopulver 200 gramm
mehl und später für die füllung noch 200
gramm
es ist ganz wichtig dass er ich habe
keine reue hat den transporten sieht man
es runter geklappt ist ich find's ganz
wichtig dass er ganze haselnüsse nimmt
und die selber zerkleinern einfach wegen
dem aroma die sind dann viel automatisch
ab jetzt gehe es zuerst die butter in
eine rührschüssel
nein kommt puderzucker mit rein könnte
man vorher auch sieben muss aber hat
sodann vanille extrakt wie immer und
eine prise salz und dann wird es jetzt
einfach mal kurz verrührt und ich gebe
auch schon mal die prüfer mit rein
auch eine gute brite
jetzt kommen noch die eigelbe mit rein
und sobald sie gut verrührt sind gehe
ich einfach noch die restlichen
trockenen zutaten meter
der teig ist jetzt relativ fest das
heißt wenn ihr den jetzt ausrollen
ausstechen wollt könnt ihr das so ganz
gut machen
ich möchte jetzt aber auf spritzen
deswegen gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen milch mit rein damit ein
bisschen also bisschen feuchter werden
nicht so trocken ist und ich ihn dann
eben gleich gut auf spritzen kann
ich benutze jetzt zum spritzen einige
beck presse ich habe da eine aus metall
die sind einfach qualitativ hochwertiger
als fc aus kunststoff und gehen halt
nicht so kaputt
jetzt fühle ich da den teig 1 aber wie
gesagt könnte denn auch einfach
ausstechen oder zum beispiel auch mit
dem spritzbeutel aufspritzen da vorne
habe ich jetzt so eine scheibe
reingelegt ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
was darstellen soll
aber es ist mir ganz gut gefallen jetzt
kann ich das hier draufsetzen und die
plätzchen formen
die päckchen kommen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 175 grad für
ungefähr neun minuten dann hole ich sie
raus und lasst sie komplett abkühlen
bevor sie dann mit der nogat creme
bestrichen werden
die nutzer plätzen sind jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt nämlich dass not und muss ich
schmelzen und mache jetzt direkt in
einem gefrierbeutel den habe ich jetzt
hier über dem spritzbeutel sterne
einfach ausgebreitet man kann nichts
besser befüllen und darin können wir das
auch direkt schmelzen
da haben wir einfach ein wenig
schließlich die tüte jetzt habe ich hier
wasser abgekocht und hängt es einfach
war ein
dann kann es nämlich darin schmelzen und
sobald geschmolzen ist geht es gleich
weiter
das lokal ist jetzt geschmolzen so ein
paar feste teilweise noch drin aber ich
habe das jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
in den händen verknetet soll auch nicht
zu flüssig sein
jetzt schneide ich oben eine ganz kleine
spitze ab jetzt werden immer zwei kekse
übereinander gesetzt also immer ein
bisschen locker drin
auch nicht so viel damit nicht
auseinander läuft und dann kommt der
zweite obendrauf hat ganz gewiss es
abkühlt
di luca plätzen sind jetzt fertig aber
für die dekoration habe ich jetzt hier
noch ein bisschen weißer schokolade
geschmolzen
auch wieder im gefrierbeutel mit namen
kleine loch vorne und das kommt es
einfach hier bisschen drüber
17 die plätzchen fertig dekoriert ich
habe noch ein paar zucker streusel
darüber gegeben sieht nämlich richtig
hübsch aus und die samira darf jetzt
probieren
der ganze okay also der murat muss immer
die plätzchen abbeißen manche muss sagt
weil er sie immer so schnell ist sage
ich hier muss menschen abweisen und die
genießen als thema mit einem haps weg
und schmeckt gut
das glaube ich finde die kekse
superlecker denn sie sind sehr
schokoladig und durch den lukas hat mir
ebenso diesem haselnuss geschmack mit
drin und ich werde jetzt gleich auch
wieder verpacken wieder in keksdosen da
privatmann kekse am besten auf und wenn
ihr das rezept nach machen wollt könnt
ihr auf meinem blog auf sase - blog.de
da gibt es auch noch ganz viele weitere
weihnachts rezepte und ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr auch da mal reinschaut
also viel spaß zum nachbacken und bis
zum nächsten mal
ich glaube du willst es hat so etwas der
mut geklaut